Hé, allons dans un nouveau monde différent d'ici
Je n'ai jamais voulu t'emmener avec moi
Un nouveau monde à offrir
[musique]
C'est un nouveau monde, c'est exactement ce que je veux
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[musique]
[applaudissements]
différence
Je ne sais pas où c'est ni ce que vous êtes.
Non, mais c'est mon ennemi.
Gênez Newa
Ce sont des meurtriers, ils disent que nous ne sommes pas les bienvenus.
C'est évident que ça va arriver, je ne le vois pas
Est-ce OK?
[musique]
[applaudissements]
C'est quoi ce visage d'Akushima ? C'est une femme. C'est une barbare.
Après tout, qui suis-je ?
Même si nos têtes explosent à mort après 60 heures de génie
Une deuxième étape d'un criminel qui ne se réalise pas
s'accroupir
mais
O.G.